welcome to Marwin is the most original
film of the year what happened to you I
got beaten within an inch of my life
because I was different some Nazi thugs
jumped him so I created a world where I
can be anyone I want these are the women
of Marwan
cough it does people you know yeah
there's bar Lala you can't keep on
running away [ __ ] I got your back
Roberta and Nicole I just moved any
Christmas gene this is hoagie kind of a
braver version of me were one in the
same pal
I thought I heard you yelling for more
gumbo not gumbo no gumbo this Christmas
the only way you're gonna get better is
if you face those jerks who beat you up
based on an inspirational true story of
a man who turned treasure
I got you what you got to embrace their
kmart into triumph I have my art and I
have my friends I have hope that's
something they can't take away from me
tail yeah
from the groundbreaking director of
force go don't just imagine yourself as
a hero be one in real life
welcome to home you are safe
welcome to healing to life to love to
Marwan
welcome to Marwan
[Music]
you